hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to talk about internal
power
this is something i really don't like
talking about very much anymore because
um i feel like there's kind of a
nonsense factory that just kind of
produces nonsense about this
unendingly and there is no escape from
it um that being said i believe there is
something that's being pointed out with
internal power and i think there are
some legitimate teachers who say they
teach internal power or internal things
and and they're legitimately describing
some real stuff that's happening however
there are demonstrations of these things
that are so fantastical that a lot of
times people equate internal power with
magic power there's also kind of
confusion whether internal power is
spiritual stuff or internal power is a
body skill or internal power is an
inherent skill or an energetic skill or
all kinds of stuff around this
i also want to separate saying internal
power from um internal chinese martial
arts i believe there's a distinction
between those two things internal
chinese martial arts is a
valid section of martial arts to be
studied i've studied them with an expert
in internal chinese martial arts and
then there's what's the other extreme
side of that is people who study uh
ipitis right so internal power internal
strength internal training
and when you see uh that kind of stuff a
lot of times those guys it's not that
they're
i think there are some more devious
versions of that and i think there's
some less devious versions of that but
basically there are some things that
they do that can seem very impressive
i'm going to show you a series of these
demonstrations
and
when seen through the wrong lens can be
misconstrued as something that they are
not they are basically just ways to be
efficient and efficient uses of the body
they are available to anyone in fact you
use them all the time you just don't
know it anything that you do right and
efficiently you probably use some
internal power principles when doing it
but then there's a lot of people who
like to say oh only certain people who
have the skill who got to sit for six
years on a mountain and breathe through
their belly and hit their heads with red
bricks or whatever whatever
magic secret thing is
that's the only way you're going to get
it so
i'm going to get josh out here we're
going to go over a few things i'm going
to break this up into sections because
there's several sections i think you
need to understand
this is a organization i made for myself
when i was trying to
debunk a lot of this stuff and i was
kind of going through and saying like
well that's just this this is just this
and i realized that there are just some
basic themes that are used over and over
and over and they're kind of
misconstrued as different things so
today we're going to talk about levers
and leverage and how that's used in
internal strength internal power
internal training and i'm gonna get josh
over here we're gonna make a simple
demonstration for you guys josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're going to talk about
the mysteries of
internal power
there's a few different things those
uh
line out to right so one of the things
is leverage another one is
muscle distraction another one is force
angle
another one is joining force so those
are the ways i kind of break it down to
when you see these demonstrations that
look really amazing you're probably
seeing one of those really simple
principles those are real legitimate
principles of physics or anything else
that you can use you use them in martial
arts systems all the time you probably
use them in your regular life all the
time the the muckety muck of it and the
stuff that makes me mad is when people
get into like oh that guy's vetted to be
a real internal master you know and uh i
think a lot of this is just kind of
nonsense so i'm gonna show you some
stuff with leverage and some of it's
kind of interesting and cool and you can
kind of apply that to things you see and
you can see how you get these
demonstrations so maybe at the end if
you guys are interested i'll make a
video me doing some of these
demonstrations um or maybe i'll get
someone real small and and cute to do it
and be better okay
all right so we're talking about
leverage so leverage is just any time
we're using a lever so i got a big long
lever so it would really magnify things
uh awesomely and right here we have 20
pounds that i stuck a strap on so i got
a 20 pound weight there josh just pick
up the 20 pound weight
right okay so not not terribly hard for
josh's full-grown man he can easily pick
up 20 pounds okay now uh can you go to
the end of this lever here maybe i don't
want to get you off frame but i'll set
this up okay now once you get both hands
on this lever and i'm going to thread
that strap through there and now i want
you to pick up that 20 pound weight
okay same 20 pounds right but now the
stick's bending josh is working real
hard and the weight didn't budge any and
there's no faking you can tell there's
no faking because the stick's bending
right it's like
just a ton of weight right and that's
because as this weight goes out on the
lever arm its weight
relatively gets magnified and that's not
true and we can get into physics about
it but it's not really important but
for his purposes its weight gets
magnified because he's got to move the
weight so much further from that end
that it's just really hard and he can't
get it to go anywhere all right now i
could make this his job a little easier
i'll put a fulcrum in here now he just
pushes down on that weight oh look and
it comes up easy again right okay now
look it only moved that much for how
much he moved it over there but it still
came up and it was easy yeah easy
super easy okay so that's one thing to
understand is how long is the lever arm
we're using
to do the work now it's a simple
demonstration you might see in class
physics whatever
intro to science whatever right
but that can be done in lots of really
tricky ways that becomes hard to see
right so for example let's just say
josh's job okay josh's job is to move
this weight and he's going to move it
sideways from the end of that stick okay
and you got to kind of lock it in there
he's pushing as hard as he can i should
probably move because he'll whack me all
right so he's pushing are you pushing
hard yeah all right i can see the stick
bending he's pushing as hard as you can
and that weight won't move at all right
okay now i can line the weight up with
it and now push the weight and move the
weight oh
amazingly easy right why is it so easy
and that was just a little angle change
now why did that happen well because the
lever arm is almost nothing when he's in
this configuration right there are no
angles to it so it's essentially a
straight line so it's just like he's
pushing with his hand it's easy for him
to push 20 pounds but if it's at 90
degrees to that and he tries to push it
he can't right suddenly it feels so
heavy so this is one of the tricks
that's done and i say tricks and i mean
you can you can take that for whatever
it is right like trick meaning it
deceives people now that could be used
for deceptive purposes like you know
like now give me 500 a month and i'll
teach you these secret things that's one
kind of deception another kind of
deception is simply here's something you
don't understand let me help you
understand that right so if josh were to
hold my arm sideways like this right and
i try to push josh over and be real
strong for me i try to push him over
like this this is really hard for me to
do because i have a lever arm now if i
line that lever arm up straight like
this super easy for me to push josh over
all of a sudden and that's because i did
the exact same thing that i did with
that stick right i aligned the lever in
a way that there was no length to the
lever arm right and when i was working
with these ideas i started calling this
shortening lever length right and i
don't like that because it's all just
really a part of leverage is the truth
but if you're trying to push if i'm
trying to push josh like this it's hard
to push because this lever links this
long but if i can line that lever up
here now it just got really easy so all
i'm doing is i'm shortening the length
of the lever the lever is this long
right now when i get it here essentially
because i'm pushing from my elbow
because i'm using my body it's
essentially nothing right so i can boom
i can do that another trick i can use
with this and there's lots of ways to do
this but foreign
let's say josh locks my arms down to the
ground right so oh it's so hard but i
can use leverage on my leg to get my
arms up and then once he's straight i
can shove him away from me right so i
can literally drive my arms down either
side and come up so even though he's
pushing my arms down i can get him up
right and that's not i know people have
seen the demonstration i'm not showing
the demonstration we will get around to
in another one we're going to go to
force angle for another one um but but
you can see that i could use the
leverage here to line this up right just
like i did with the yoga block there and
then once the lever arm length is about
zero i can drive into them really really
easy so leverage is something that is
really deceptive to people if you show
most people that i think they would be
surprised that 20 pounds is so heavy on
the end of an eight foot lever and the
same thing is true if you see
demonstrations where you get a little
guy and they're picked up in the air so
easily and then all of a sudden they
become so heavy and they fall back down
to the ground well all they're doing is
lengthening the lever arm and they can
do that in lots of ways you can do it
forward backwards sideways so angles
tend to deceive us when we're looking at
things especially for looking in videos
or pictures because they're
two-dimensional and when you add that
third dimension you can't see that
there's actually an angle going on
that's hard for you to pick out so a lot
of stuff would leverage that you really
already understand you know anybody need
to pick up something heavy they would
grab a lever and try and do that or
you're turning a bolt and you lengthen
your wrench you know that the bolt will
be easier to turn so stuff that you do
all the time is part of this
continuum of ipitis stuff it's just
whether we talk about it like the big
giant mystery or we talk about it like
oh it's something you can get a handle
on if you think about it more right and
i'm i'm a big fan of let's talk about it
like it's a thing we can get a handle on
because
i think it's too easy to deceive people
already the world's already full of so
much
confusing things that when you come to a
martial arts system you should be making
things simpler so i hope that
demonstration of leverage helped you if
there's some more stuff you'd like to
seek there's more stuff i could do with
leverage it's just i think this is kind
of the gross ideas of it like being able
to see the angles of the lever and how
it works and
and how you can shorten that lever
length and how that makes a big
difference and how you can add a fulcrum
to give you more power that is one of
the most important things and leverage
of course is essential in all jiu-jitsu
and aikido any kind of grappling already
kind of thing we're holding and
manipulating things even we're using
weapons we're using the lever length of
the weapon to to enact uh power trade of
sorts so i'm christopher hein this is
joshua tihi and behind that camera is
maya solano mcdaniel we're going to be
back in the next uh video series i'm
going to talk about force angle so we'll
see you next time
[Music]